it was a lot of fun
[Music]
it's a scene that could have been fun
and I enjoyed both doing it and
seeing it afterwards when it was edited
so a feeling of pure well-being
let's say
adobe you can see it
no nothing yet uncle
would you spend some wine with
your people I hope intense pico su questo
fluence time that away
sharing set with this change act of
italian cinema events the kind lady
having fun video files of evil frone
seigniorage to call the worst harm
in naples on this stage what was there
important was to tell the
wonder of the
summer of being young and
the enchantment of summer Sunday in
my city according to my memory it
was the story of a joyful moment
that in perception the memory making
a record is burned
and collecting let's say this feeling
is this intention of paolo that there was
between writing and
state
to indulge the joy of these characters this so beautiful moment of
spens  solemnity
[Music]
[Applause]
his
comeback months cli to go past
the sunday with my family has arrived
ascension family is yours
technically in short
to ensure that there is
spontaneity and as a word he thought
we shot in a very  tightened with
the last course of a room 3 lipari
are scared
in short the
sequence the whole
city
[Music]
the moment so vilar and worms
and it is also not there while we were actually filming
also because they participated in short
this was felt precisely this if  this
atmosphere
like how he had staged it how he
had written it that is I think but
my non di no at least for me it
seemed a lot it was like reliving
Sundays with my family too and
on the still he serves he says that  to me he and
I strongly doubt
incredible times sharing my sweet
in italy tris toni
renato carpentieri and he remains ace
adusbef excite what western that
moment on
itunes from trial of motion
emotion
there is also  harrier and the
alberti telescopes the boy is in classical high school
uses he shows himself but what can I say
he frames everyone from time to time and
everyone talks and everyone gets whipped up
and everyone takes their moment I
think the brilliance of the scene is
due to the  brilliance of the actors and
the underground relationship of joy
and contentment that the actors had with
each other while being on the set he closes
one eye c control and sanity of the
screens the vets and those in gambini
unique gift like champagne in my opinion he is
a beautiful figure
you will see  first entry idiot ends up in
jail you will see go you can see nothing
ago
not only for this kind sinte ris pacs
important improbable the steps
in the working
of
actors
if he would have said of tartars
ouch ouch
ouch ouch ouch
the preparation we say because
we prepare
we look  the place and
compared to how written let's say I follow
an intention directed by paolo
story and based on that
or  I organized, let's say about the technical issues
because then,
needing to carry out this scene in
a very fluid, spontaneous way,
let's say it was organized to
shoot in sequence and
above all the progress was respected, the rhythm of the
scene, not the other issues which
could, let's say, be techniques for  which
the preparation will be the moment in which
we have chosen in short paola chosen
place we have seen the place we have
decided to put the post in a
position how
to set
the environment scenically however then we have gone
quite arm but it is not that there will be
a big one and therefore from  for my part there
was trying to
satisfy
his will the rhythm of the actors
trying to be less
intrusive and
annoying as possible trying to
also be very levee in moving the
cameras in making cameras turn
together so it was a very
light scheme let's say what can I say
that we have midday as an
action scene but in short words  che non
era
amico com'ero fresco ago a number
brovazzo
right after stromboli we wish destin and
now the members of the
icc guide with marlon these miss up it
was like tomorrow delrio brother and
highly members destin ai vips in home ed past
enthusiasm of brothers days in  it with
another brother where just have to to be
there have to your
renato carpentieri franco pinelli toni
servillo or the story in dts but the
driving force and it was very very
interesting it was light credit
jumping meals however you know that
my friend matt  barter rino lamb has
practically closed for mara parties there
is no such thing as the cold i don't believe you
what can i say maradona was a
view of maradona and those days
he
admitted we Neapolitans lowered by
soccer Neapolitans above all
football enthusiasts in a state
of pleasant expectation  in short, it was a
summer with the features of Christmas,
the advent was expected,
he believes us tour angeletti madini will be
hotter and in greater quantity  elli goes to
get coffee from his friend
right turn what a [ __ ] two elements decrees
that a maradona comes to play naples
all [ __ ] who write the newspapers
to sell copies yes that's fine I can't
say he was waiting for him because I still didn't
quite understand but afterwards  a bit that he had
arrived became a kind of myth
because he was genius and recklessness
and therefore he was likeable
ceravolo a
controversial character but for
this very fascinating so
still in maradona for everything
he did
and for what he represented
for us too  in that historical moment
he never expended a lira for her I know
ferlaino well the punk mobile
ios and maradona always comes he is not loved I'll kill myself
you understood correctly what I told
you I'll kill you